cuando me formaba como ingeniero civil
llevé una clase que se llama
procedimientos de construcción y
recuerdo perfectamente la primera clase
en el capítulo 1 hablamos de trabajos
preliminares todo eso que se tiene que
hacer antes de construir cualquier
edificación o cualquier infraestructura
una vez que ya se tiene el proyecto
ejecutivo
y en el sub capítulo 1.1
discutíamos sobre cómo talar árboles
cómo intervenir en los ecosistemas si
hablábamos de cómo teníamos que destruir
para poder construir más tarde también
escuché las experiencias de mis
profesores que me hablaban de que cuando
se desarrollaban obras hidráulicas muy
grandes u obras de vías terrestres pues
era inevitable desplazar a las
comunidades o destruir los ecosistemas
como aprendimos en la clase de
procedimientos de construcción
en algún momento como estudiante
universitario idealista me cuestiones
sobre cómo era posible que tuviéramos
que destruir las comunidades y los
ecosistemas para poder construir nuestra
infraestructura parecía contradictorio
sin embargo en otro momento también
pensé bueno pero dejar de construir
infraestructura tampoco es una opción
si lo piensas nuestra civilización
depende en gran medida de los servicios
que ofrecen nuestra infraestructura agua
energía alimentos transporte salud
etcétera entonces
no hay manera de dejar de construir pero
estamos destruyendo
al final reflexione que no es una
discusión binaria el desarrollo
sostenible no es una discusión binaria
no es ser sostenible o no ser sostenible
en absoluto no se trata de construye o
destruye
en realidad en medio hay una escala de
grises en la cual tenemos que caminar
orientados hacia la sostenibilidad y
sobre eso quiero compartir una reflexión
este día
hoy vivimos la crisis de la pandemia de
kobe 19
y ella ha puesto en evidencia muchas de
las crisis que ya vivíamos
por un lado la crisis de la naturaleza y
de hecho la pandemia es un síntoma de
ella
la evidencia científica sugiere que
detrás de la transmisión del virus sars
cop 2 a los humanos están justamente la
depredación
de los ecosistemas y la pérdida de
biodiversidad
pero estos problemas no son los únicos
que están reunidos en esa crisis también
está en el cambio climático también está
la disrupción en el flujo de nutrientes
que se manifiesta en cuestiones como la
presencia de sargazo en las playas está
también la introducción de especies
invasoras y este el hermano siniestro
del cambio climático
la acidificación del océano
entonces independientemente de que estos
problemas se vayan a resolver oa mitigar
en alguna medida en el futuro lo que sí
es seguro es que impondrán nuevas
condiciones a las que tendremos que
adaptarnos
por otro lado la pandemia también
acentúa la crisis de desigualdad que ya
vivíamos y esto se manifestó de
múltiples maneras pero me referiría dos
en particular que tienen que ver
directamente con la infraestructura
por un lado hoy tenemos claro que
lavarse las manos es una medida de
prevención de kobe 19 y muchos de
nosotros lo hacemos con bastante
naturalidad
sin embargo mientras aquí platicamos hay
2000 millones de personas en el mundo
que no tienen acceso a agua potable en
sus viviendas
al mismo tiempo durante esta temporada
alrededor de 450 millones de niños en el
mundo dejaron de tener acceso a la
educación por múltiples causas pero
indudablemente una de ellas fue la
deficiencia en la cobertura de
electricidad en la cobertura de
telecomunicaciones
entonces se tienen dos crisis tenemos
dos crisis la crisis de naturaleza y la
crisis de desigualdad y no tengo duda de
que vamos a necesitar infraestructura
para atender estas crisis
porque cuando hablo de infraestructura
no son solamente grandes obras
hidráulicas o carreteras de cientos o
miles de kilómetros o edificios de
decenas o cientos de metros de altura
también son intervenciones medianas en
las ciudades intervenciones pequeñas en
las comunidades de tal manera que el
desarrollo sea incluyente
hoy en día muchas de nuestras obras de
infraestructura aparecen cuestionables
ciudades tapizadas de concreto asfáltico
y que hoy no permiten la recarga natural
de los acuíferos y que ocasionan
inundaciones
ríos que en su momento tuvieron que
entubar se lagos que en su momento se
drenaron para poder construir ciudades
sobre ellos parece cuestionables todas
estas obras sin embargo es claro que
respondieron a las necesidades que
existían en ese momento respondieron al
contexto en que se encontraba la
civilización en aquel entonces y hoy
estamos obligados a hacer lo mismo
debemos continuar desarrollando nuestra
infraestructura pero con soluciones
adecuadas al contexto en el que nos
encontramos y el contexto en el que nos
encontramos está caracterizado por las
dos crisis que se mencionaron la crisis
de la naturaleza y la crisis de
desigualdad
nuestros proyectos de infraestructura
tienen cinco fases
la planeación el diseño la construcción
la operación y el mantenimiento y
entonces la infraestructura sostenible
que es el enfoque que se necesita para
desarrollar la infraestructura en
comunión con la naturaleza con el
desarrollo social y con el desarrollo
económico tiene cuatro dimensiones
la dimensión institucional
la dimensión financiera la dimensión
socioeconómica y la dimensión ambiental
antes me refería a las últimas dos pero
es necesario explicar las primeras dos
para poder entrar en contexto
con respecto a la sostenible
institucional es claro que el horizonte
político y el horizonte de desarrollo
están desalineados en el tiempo aquí en
méxico el horizonte político es de 36
años en otros países será diferente pero
el horizonte de desarrollo y en la vida
útil de nuestras infraestructuras está
en otro horizonte 2030 50 años esta
desalineación que existe entre el
horizonte de desarrollo y el horizonte
político ocasiona que frecuentemente los
proyectos dejen de tener continuidad que
se les deje de dar prioridad o incluso
que se cancelen
de esta manera entonces surge la
necesidad de institucionalizar la
planeación de infraestructura lo que se
requiere es una política de estado que
establezca claramente cuáles son las
prioridades para el desarrollo que haya
una cartera de programas y proyectos que
se necesitan para el desarrollo del país
y luego que los gobiernos instrumento en
esa política con sus propios planes y
programas pero dentro del horizonte
político para que haya concordancia
además hoy en día estamos viendo que
mucha de nuestra infraestructura está
alcanzando su vida útil
las carreteras se están modernizando las
redes de agua potable se están cambiando
por completo y eso es evidencia de que
ya están alcanzando su vida útil
entonces esa infraestructura también
debe incorporarse a estos planes y
programas para que al pararle lo que se
desarrolla nueva infraestructura se
pueda continuar operando y mantener la
infraestructura que ya tenemos
además los alcances de estos programas
deben reflejarse en la escala sub
nacional aquí en méxico hablamos de
estados y municipios de tal manera que
como mencioné anteriormente el
desarrollo sea incluyente
en seguida esto está estrechamente
relacionado con el financiamiento porque
seguramente has visto que algún edificio
alguna obra importante dejó de
terminarse porque no hubo recursos
porque no hubo dinero para poder
continuar con ella y esto no puede
seguir pasando en el futuro
antes los gobiernos con los recursos que
recauda van bien puestos eran quienes
financiaban la construcción de
infraestructura con el tiempo y con el
crecimiento en la demanda de servicios
pues esa fuente ya no fue suficiente se
tuvieron que diversificar las fuentes de
financiamiento y eso no va a cambiar en
el futuro el papel de organismos
internacionales de bancos de desarrollo
y de la iniciativa privada será cada vez
más importante
esto desde luego conlleva a desafíos
legales y regulatorios pero que tendrán
que atenderse porque son necesarios para
poder materializar esta infraestructura
además
nuestros proyectos también deben crear
valor en muchos casos se habla de que
los proyectos sean rentables en otros
casos más bien se habla de que deben
crear valor
y construir infraestructura puede tener
múltiples motivaciones una de ellas por
ejemplo es impulsar la economía en
tiempos de crisis como los que hoy
vivimos
pero eso no debe estar peleado con que
la infraestructura responda a
necesidades legítimas de la ciudadanía
si se va a construir una carretera de un
punto a un punto b que no sea solamente
para impulsar la economía sino que esa
necesidad realmente exista para que el
proyecto pueda crear valor
en seguida
se han documentado en los últimos años
las lecciones de proyectos de
infraestructura que fracasaron por la
oposición de la ciudadanía y la
conclusión a la que se llegó fue que
hizo falta participación ciudadana la
presión social fue tan importante que
los proyectos tuvieron que cancelarse o
que tuvieron que dejar de construirse
porque la ciudadanía no los quería
y esta tendencia se mantendrá en el
futuro y además es congruente con la
crisis de desigualdad que hoy vivimos
entonces en ese sentido el rol del
estado es garantizar la transparencia de
los alcances de los proyectos tanto en
beneficios porque no también como en
perjuicios
y además facilitar los mecanismos de
participación ciudadana para qué
la gente de las comunidades se puede
involucrar en los procesos de consulta o
de foros o de diálogo con las
autoridades y que puedan externar todas
sus dudas y sus inquietudes sobre el
proyecto
al mismo tiempo el rol de la ciudadanía
es involucrarse activamente de manera
informada pero especialmente de manera
libre eso es muy importante y es una es
otra de las dimensiones de la
infraestructura sostenible
finalmente la dimensión ambiental pues
habla de que las obras de
infraestructura deben reducir sus
impactos ambientales y a este respecto
el instrumento de la evaluación de
impacto ambiental es muy importante pero
se requiere monitorear las medidas de
mitigación que ahí se proponen para
garantizar que estén teniendo los
efectos deseados
además en los últimos años ha surgido
una tendencia para complementar la
evaluación de impacto ambiental que es
la evaluación ambiental estratégica y
ésta puede aplicar a megaproyectos de
infraestructura o puede aplicar a
programas de infraestructura de tal
manera que se pueda elegir entre
distintas alternativas aquella que tenga
el menor impacto ambiental
también aquí se vuelve necesario
incorporar elementos de innovación en
diseño y en materiales y procedimientos
de construcción por ejemplo hoy en
arquitectura existe la tendencia de la
biofilia la biofilia tiene que ver con
la incorporación de elementos de la
naturaleza en el diseño arquitectónico y
en el diseño urbano para poder tener
esta comunión de el desarrollo social
con la protección de la naturaleza y
desde luego con el desarrollo económico
además
también se requieren nuevos materiales
se requiere tecnología nueva de
materiales de construcción para poder
crear materiales que sean de una menor
huella de carbono que requieran menos
energía para poderse fabricar y que
tengan una menor huella hídrica que
requieran menos agua para poder
producirse y además se necesitan nuevas
técnicas y herramientas en los métodos
de construcción abrazar las metodologías
que permiten hacer un uso más eficiente
de los recursos en la construcción
y finalmente nuestra infraestructura
también debe ser resiliente
estamos expuestos y la infraestructura
también a múltiples fenómenos fenómenos
geológicos fenómenos sanitarios como la
pandemia que hoy vivimos fenómenos
químicos explosiones y cosas de ese
estilo y especialmente a fenómenos
hidrometeorológicos
y estos tienen una particularidad y es
que se ven acentuados por el cambio
climático y entonces nuestra
infraestructura debe de ser capaz de
soportar los efectos de estos fenómenos
especialmente de sequías e inundaciones
recapitulando empecé diciendo que la
discusión de la sostenibilidad no es
binaria no se trata de ser sostenible o
no ser sostenible en absoluto
sino que hay una escala de grises en
medio y debemos caminar hacia la
sostenibilidad
también mencioné que tenemos dos crisis
hoy que son la crisis de la naturaleza y
la crisis de desigualdad y también dije
que se necesita infraestructura para
atender estas crisis grandes proyectos
sí pero también proyectos medianos
proyectos pequeños que sean incluyentes
no podemos dejar de construir
infraestructura nuestra civilización
está soportada en gran medida por ella
lo que sí podemos hacer es construirla
con un enfoque diferente por eso
necesitamos a la infraestructura
sostenible
y en resumen la infraestructura
sostenible tiene cuatro dimensiones la
sostenibilidad institucional la
financiera la socioeconómica y la
ambiental
y para terminar se mencionar yo se
mencionaron varios aspectos que debe de
tener debe estar planeada a largo plazo
para que haya una congruencia entre el
horizonte político y el de desarrollo
debe tener financiamiento suficiente y
adecuado
debe crear valor porque hoy día todos
valoramos lavarnos las manos para
prevenir el contagio de kobe 19
debe involucrar a la ciudadanía con
mecanismos adecuados y debe reducir y
mitigar sus impactos ambientales
y quiero terminar con el siguiente
comentario
pues sí
mis colegas de ingeniería civil tendrán
que seguir estudiando el sub capítulo
1.1 de la clase de procedimientos de
construcción la diferencia está en que
tendremos que asumir la responsabilidad
socioambiental que ello implica
pero además también quedó claro que la
planeación y el desarrollo de
infraestructura no es un asunto
únicamente de ingenieros de economistas
y de políticos es un asunto que nos
preocupa y nos debe ocupar a todos
porque si todos nos involucramos
podremos conectar las piezas de la
infraestructura sostenible y de esa
manera podremos construir sin destruir
muchas gracias